I am going to try my level best here I'm
gonna really try folks I will attempt to
remain calm to not start screaming as we
discuss this story but I must admit that
I am I am fairly seething with a with a
deep and primal rage at the moment now
if you watch this show you know that the
thing that sets me off more than
anything else the thing that sends me
into spasms of anger on this show is
when children are hurt exploited abused
you know and you might say well
obviously that upsets you that upsets
everybody well it should shouldn't it
but it doesn't you know I shouldn't have
to sit here and say I really hate child
abuse I'm against it that shouldn't be
the kind of thing that you even need to
talk about on a show like this because
it should be something we all agree on
should be a position we all share so
that's so that talking about it would be
redundant and unnecessary but guys we
live in a country where in fact lots of
people and lots of powerful people as we
will see in a minute are fully in favor
of child abuse in many forms they're in
favor of killing children in the womb
and if the child manages to escape the
womb with his life intact then these
same people these disgusting monstrous
scumbags will set to work attempting to
destroy the child emotionally
psychologically through all manner of
physical and emotional and psychological
and sexual abuse and exploitation there
are many people and again many powerful
people in our country who see children
as objects that can be exploited and
used or just discarded if you don't want
them that's the backdrop here as we as
we get into the topic at hand and the
topic at hand is the case of
james-younger a seven-year-old boy son
of Jeff younger and quote-unquote mother
and
George Ellis and Georgia list by the way
is not only the quote-unquote mother but
she's also a quote-unquote doctor a
pediatrician of all things now um so
let's let lets let's back up here and do
some background on this case Jeff and
Ann and I guess I'm just gonna use their
first names here as we talk about it
just because it's easier so Jeff and Ann
were married but ended up getting
divorced actually I think it might have
been an annulment I'm not sure don't
quote me on that but in any case the
marriage ended one way or another and as
is usually the case with with these
sorts of things the quote/unquote mother
was given most of the rights over the
child because that's the sort of default
position that the courts have that
family courts have most of the time
where they're just going to assume that
the mother is the more fit parent
because she's a woman but remember women
are the ones who are legally oppressed
in this country remember that anyway the
mother has given most of the power over
the child eventually the mother decides
that the boy James is actually a girl
named Luna now remember that did James
right now is seven years old so he's
very very young but this all started a
few years ago in fact he was three years
old when it started he was three when
the mother decided that he was a girl do
you want to know how the quote-unquote
mother made this discovery well an
article in in the in the Texan explains
it so here's a quote from the Texan
article says conflict arose in the next
few years and their marriage was
eventually annulled while the court okay
so I wasn't Holman all right well the
while the court made the the parents
joint managing conservatory
you're jealous was given exclusive
rights and duties while youngers were
limited George Ellis says that James
first wanted a girls toy from McDonald's
and soon after starting and soon after
started imitating the female characters
from diz
he's frozen and asked to wear dresses
she says she then contacted the genesis
clinic at Children's Hospital Center and
they refer to to refer to her to Rebecca
or for counseling and then that person
recommended a process of affirmation and
and they thought that a social
transition for James to begin going to
school dressed as a girl named Luna
would be in his best interest so that's
how the quote/unquote mother figured out
that little James is really just a shell
you know he James it really didn't exist
it turns out James was a shell he was a
James shell but trapped inside that
shell of a body was this little girl
named Luna who was just itching to get
out this is science
by the way this is this is all science
uh and she figured that out because
James wanted a girl toy from McDonald's
oh and he also likes the movie frozen
well that's it then that settles it
Eureka I mean there couldn't possibly be
any other explanation for why this boy
was interested in a Disney film couldn't
possibly be any other explanation he
must really be a girl I said I wasn't
gonna scream let me pull back a little
bit now of course by this standard
literally every other every boy by this
standard is a girl and every girl's a
boy because every boy is interested in
some things that are associated with
girls and every little girl's interested
in some things that are associated with
boys so if that's the case then every
girl's a boy every boy's a girl nothing
means anything what does it even matter
in that case and and and by the way I
thought we were done
gendering toys right I thought there was
no such thing as a girl toy or a boy toy
wasn't that the whole thing with target
where they stopped they didn't have the
girl toy aisle or the boy toy aisle
anymore because whether you're a boy or
girl
could play with any toy that that was
the point but now you're saying that if
a boy plays with it with a toy that's
associated with girls it's really an
indication that he actually is a girl
trapped in a boy's body so have you not
just then reaffirmed the the gendering
of toys except for the quote-unquote
mother there was a hiccup
because when James went to his father's
house he was still identifying as a boy
imagine that and going by the name James
and wearing boy clothes and all of that
because he is a boy and he wants to be a
boy the quote/unquote mother couldn't
have that she couldn't allow the father
to interfere with the abuse of the child
that she was you know she was she really
had been putting a lot of effort into
abusing this child and she didn't want
the father interfering with that so
eventually it goes to the courts both
parents fighting essentially for sole
custody and the court just ruled
yesterday this is in Texas remember in
Texas the court ruled yesterday against
the father the mother is now given
basically sole power and authority the
father will not be will probably not get
any unsupervised visits with his own son
who I guess the court believes is really
his daughter and the mother can now if
she wants start the process of
chemically castrating the boy she can
now force him to live full-time as a
girl and she can poison him with
chemicals to permanently alter his body
so that she can live out her fantasies
fantasies that she has imposed on her
child well actually not really her child
that's the icing on the cake here I've
been calling her the quote/unquote
mother because she is an abusive monster
and does not deserve to be called the
mother she is not a mother she is not
acting like one she is not the this is
not how mothers behave she doesn't
deserve so so it's it's only for lack of
a better term that I use this term
mother for her but it's also worth
noting that actually technically she
isn't even biologically the mother
the child was conceived with a donor egg
she isn't even biologically related to
this kid and yet she has been given the
power to do what she wants to him and
with him it's amazing now it's true that
James doesn't really want to be a girl
this identity has been foisted on him by
this despicable lunatic who fashions
herself a mother and and I want you to
understand I'm being very harsh in the
way that I described this woman but
that's because what she is doing is pure
evil and if we lived in a country where
things made sense and where there were
where there was justice and where we
cared about protecting children this
person would be locked in prison for the
rest of her life because that's where
she deserves to be this is a very very
bad person and and this is as I have
always argued this is a form of not just
emotional and physical and psychological
abuse although as if that's not enough
it is also sexual abuse okay it is in
the most fundamental way because you are
sexually manipulating a child in fact I
want you to listen to this
the father was on a podcast recently on
he was on the Luke Macias podcast which
you can hear if you go to Luke Macias
calm my MA CIA s.com until you pronounce
the last name it's a long interview
worth listening to but I want to play
one part where he talks about how this
started what the mother did to James and
in fact right before we play this clip
or actually right before this clip that
I'm gonna play Jeff because he's talking
about what what this person did and he
says that there were various tools of
manipulation she would use in order to
create gender confusion in her innocent
and helpless son one of the things she
would do apparently according to Jeff is
she would lock the kid in a room and
tell him that there's a monster that in
there that only eats little boys
she would do that with him when he was
three years old and there was much more
to it than that
listen listen to what Jeff younger the
father has to say during the temporary
orders period when we were waiting to go
to final trial and we're going through
the endless motions before the Associate
Judge my three-year-old son tells me
he's at my home he tells me that he's a
girl and I had the presence of mind
thank goodness to pull out my iphone and
videotape me asking him about that and
that was the literally the first time
that I really understood what was
happening to my son and what did you
gather from that first conversation with
that his mother was telling him that he
was a girl she was dressing him as a
girl she was putting nail polish on him
and encouraging him to act like a girl
and my my personal assessment this isn't
from James my personal assessment was
that she was only giving him love and
affection if he acted like a girl and
that was the first time I noticed he was
it was just past his third birthday
three years old three years old so it's
obvious that James doesn't really
identify as a girl he's been forced into
this this is something that has been
done to him by that nurse ratchet of a
mother but he has been cursed with but
here's the thing it wouldn't matter even
if he did really authentically identify
as a girl it would make no difference to
to or it should make no difference to
the to the case um you know that if this
wasn't being forced on him the way that
it is that would make them up the mother
may be less of an evil scumbag
but it wouldn't change the reality and
the reality is that no matter what the
child says the child who doesn't
understand what's going on and can't
possibly understand the reality is that
he is a boy period he is a boy not a
girl doesn't know what a girl is he
doesn't
know what a boy is he doesn't understand
what it means today to transition he
doesn't understand the consequences he
doesn't understand anything because he's
a child he is just a confused child and
what he whatever he says about I'm a
girl I'm a boy these are confused
statements for my naive and innocent
little kid who doesn't know what the
hell is going on because how could he so
in some ways as we as we talked about
well you know he didn't know does he
want to be a girl does he want to be a
boy and it seems like that's what the
case really boiled down to but that just
shows you that just shows you how crazy
things have gotten because it's it's
starting from a false premise it doesn't
to argue over what does he want that
would seem to grant the premise to begin
with that a child can potentially choose
his own gender which he can't anyway no
matter what he wants but the fact that
he doesn't even want this in the first
place just makes it I suppose all the
worse you know when you follow this case
you really begin to see well you see a
few things you see that we are screwed
as a society I hate to say it this case
I I don't I don't think people really
understand just how monumental this case
is it's gotten a fair amount of tension
attention at least in conservative
circles it should be getting a lot more
attention than it actually is though
however much attention it's getting we
we should be much more focused on this
than we are because we are crossing now
a threshold with with the court making a
ruling like this in Texas of all places
can you imagine now a cases like this in
California or Washington State or New
York or New Hampshire can you imagine if
if this woman could get this ruling out
of a Texas Court imagine what a
similarly monstrous parent could achieve
in a court in a
in a state that's already crazy liberal
to begin with but the other thing that
you see illustrated is the fact that
transgender children are really a
symptom of Munchausen by pop by proxy
and I think this case is a you couldn't
you couldn't find a better illustration
of that Munchausen by proxy is when
parents pretend that their children are
sick or they make the child sick in
order to get attention or pity or
whatever else they want they did there
was the HBO miniseries what was it
called sharp objects based on a book Amy
Adams came out last year and it revolves
there might be a spoiler actually I
might have just spoiled it for you sorry
about that anyway
but it's it's revolves around around
this around this thing where you've got
a parent and this and this happens in
real life not just in movies where you
have some sick and twisted evil parents
who I think oftentimes ends up being a
mother who does this for whatever reason
but they make their kids sick and it's
all it's all just the most twisted form
of emotional manipulation or sort of
using the child as bait dangling the
sick child out there a child that you
made sick so that you can get whatever
you want out of the world essentially
caching him in as as social capital
that's what this mother has been doing
this mother for years has been making
this child sick she has infused gender
dysphoria
into his head she has caused it in order
to achieve whatever it is she hopes to
achieve for herself and that's that's
one of the reasons why I feel no
compunction about being very harsh in my
approach to this woman because there is
no way in hell especially when you
consider she's a pediatrician god help
us there is no way in hell she actually
believes this nonsense about how her
there's a daughter trapped inside her
son's body there's no way she really
believes that no no one who understands
anything about science anyone who has
any medical training there is no
you possibly believe that especially
when you as the mother know that you
have been working on this with the kid
practically since he was born so this is
not a case of a of a of an unfortunately
confused and misled mother no that's not
what this is but you see how you see how
strong the biological impulse is that
this in in some ways it makes it even
sadder that this poor boy has been
resisting this for years and think about
that think about what that requires that
need this has been for years now since
he was three years old his mother's been
trying to brainwash him but still when
he goes to his father's house it's like
he's relieved that he can finally take
off the freaking dress and dress like a
boy and and go and roll around in the
mud and do what boys do he still has
that impulse now eventually he will lose
it and this is what will happen after
all of this brainwashing and then
they're gonna start him on the drugs and
they're gonna chemically castrate him
and so you know 10 15 years from now if
you talk this child who now will be an
adult he'll tell you about how he
identifies as a woman and and this is
this is who he is deep inside and he's
known it since he was a little kid and
in everything this is this is really who
he is
that's what he'll tell you because
that's what he'll think about himself
people who are brainwashed don't know
they've been brainwashed but the other
thing is that even 15 years from now
when he is insisting that about himself
that he's really a woman and he's always
known this and everything he still is
going to be deeply in misery and
depressed because this is transgender
people have massively higher rates of
suicide they have lower life they have
shorter life expectancies and all of
that and for all we hear about Oates
because of bullying and because they're
not accepted in society no that's that's
not it it's because the
these are people who who struggle at
such a basic level to accept themselves
for who they really are and there is a
lot of misery and pain that comes with
that and this mother has put that on her
child all right I almost succeeded in
talking about that without screaming I
did the best I could I just I I hope
that look this is I don't know what can
be be done about this but I think that
the same people in in the government
down there in Texas if they can step in
they need to or at the very least guys
like Ted Cruz Governor Abbott they need
to speak up and say something about this
case even if they can't do anything
about it just speak up and defend this
child I know there are a lot of people
down there in Texas a lot of people in
the community that have been speaking
out and protesting I think more people
need to and people in positions of power
there need to speak up we're at a point
now where if you if you are so if you
are a sane decent person and you know
better and you know that this is crazy
and you and you understand what's
happening to these children you need to
speak up you can't stay silent anymore
you just can't alright let's let's move
on we'll see what else we've got going
on here
so there was this case the New York Post
is reporting a case out of the
University of Connecticut let me read
let me read a little bit of the
University of Connecticut or the New
York Post report it says two whites two
white students at the University of
Connecticut were arrested for shouting
racial slurs as they walk through a
parking lot outside student apartments
earlier this month according to a report
the suspects 21 year old students Jared
Carroll and Ryan
lucasz I don't know how to pronounce his
last name were arrested by campus police
Monday after they were captured on a
viral video repeatedly shouting the
n-word students launched
large rallies and protests of the video
in the campus chapter of the n-double
a-c-p demanded school officials take
action against the pair the arrests of
Carol and Mukesh were announced hours
after a march against racism now get
this these two guys were each chart they
were charged I'm quoting up charged with
ridicule on account of creed religion
color denomination nationality or race
police who investigated the case
discovered the two students walked
through the woods through the apartment
complex playing a game in which they
yelled vulgar words and there was
another student was with them and didn't
participate the game okay charged with
ridicule actually back up for a second
so you've got you've got these two two
guys walking down campus shouting bad
words playing a game stupid game I'm
sure we all agree but it's just a game
and they're just joking
inappropriate fine you want to say it's
offensive fine but that's what it is
before we even get to the fact that they
were arrested and charged with a crime
you had you had marches and rallies
about what because two two kids walking
down the street we're shouting bad words
what what do you need the march against
yeah everyone agrees that it's not good
that they did that so what are you what
all the things activism in this country
has become so completely frivolous and
you see how desperate people are for a
cause you know people need a cause to
believe in and to fight for and if
you're not gonna fight for real causes
and for things that really matter then
you're stuck with something like this
let's take to the streets and March
because two guys on the campus set a bad
word my god now but that's
that's even that's just beside the point
because the real issue here is that the
police got involved and charged them
with ridicule did you know that that was
even a crime you could be charged with
ridicule if that's a criminal offense
then every single person in America
should be in jail because everybody in
America has engaged in ridicule at some
point in their life just go on Twitter
right now go to Twitter and and all of
those people arrest all of them
every single person with a Twitter
account they all because that's what
that's the only reason Twitter exists to
ridicule people charged with a crime so
the First Amendment doesn't exist
basically is what we're learning this is
just free speech First Amendment doesn't
exist if you could be charged with a
crime for ridiculing and the thing is
they it wasn't even ridicule they
weren't even it's not even like you can
tell it was harassment they weren't
harassing it they weren't talking to
anyone they were literally just shouting
into the thin air again you can you
could say it's stupid it's offensive
it's fine I agree with you on that but
who are they ridiculing aside from
themselves if if this is illegal then
the First Amendment doesn't exist you
you don't what's what function does the
First Amendment even serve if the First
Amendment doesn't cover this then what
do you even have it for because the
whole point as as many people have
pointed out and as as always needs to be
pointed out with cases like this you
only need the First Amendment to protect
offensive speech that nobody likes
because if it's in an offensive speech
that that no one cares about or everyone
agrees with then you don't need a First
Amendment at all we don't you don't need
to specially protect that kind of speech
in fact you could go any way you can go
to North Korea and and say stuff that
people there
we'll agree with and like you could now
what what people will agree with and the
kind of speech people will like that's
gonna change depending on where you are
but you can go anywhere in the world and
say things that are culturally
appropriate according to the culture
that you happen to be in at the moment
and many of those places like North
Korea for example don't have free speech
protections because in those places they
don't have free speech what they're
saying is yeah you can say culturally
acceptable things but that's all you can
say you can't say anything that's
culturally unacceptable and that's why
we don't have a First Amendment in that
country so that's that's that's what it
is so if you say oh yes but it was it's
offensive and horrible yeah agreed
agreed agreed I agree with all of that
but yes you can say offensive and
horrible things we act like free speech
is this really complicated complex
really nuanced subject and maybe there
there are some nuances to it yes but
it's not that hard to understand and for
me when I look at how the First
Amendment is written not the language
and the spirit of it what it was meant
to do it's pretty clear to me that the
First Amendment is supposed to give you
the right to say whatever you want
provided you are not defaming or
slandering someone or otherwise you know
community trying to directly cause
physical harm to another person so the
only example of shouting fire in a
crowded theater okay of course you can't
do that unless there is a fire but if
there isn't you can't do that that is
going to directly cause harm to people
it's gonna could cause harm from the
stampede at people running out of the
theater it'll cause harm to the business
that you've just where you've just
caused all these people to go running
out so yes that's going to cause direct
harm
but other than that you can say whatever
you want that's the way it should be and
there's no real downside so you think
about what's the downside so we have to
compare on one hand you could have a
crime against ridicule and arrest people
for it or you could or you could say
well you basically say whatever you want
as long as you're not directly causing
harm to another person what's the
downside to that first plan having a
crime against having a law against
ridicule well the plus side is I guess
you're protecting people's feelings okay
the downside is you have created this
subjective law where the people in power
get to decide because what counts is
ridicule you would talk about hate
speech obviously we were I was talking
about this on Twitter and some people
were saying oh what are you what do you
support hate speech now I don't support
hate speech in in in in the in the sense
of supporting the content and advocating
the people engage in it whatever it is
but that's the point what is it
something like ridicule hate speech that
is subjective it's going to depend on
your perspective so you can have a crime
against ridicule plus-side is protect
people's feelings some people's feelings
sometimes downside is now you have given
this authority to people in power to
subjectively determine what they
consider to be hate speech and ridicule
and then to clamp down on speech by that
standard on the other hand we could say
let's not do that
and let's people let's let people say
whatever they want as long as we're not
directly causing harm to another person
plus side is now we've got free speech
we live in a free country people are
protected in their ability to express
themselves what's the downside downside
is people are going to be allowed to say
some tasteless things some crass and
crude things and it might be
kind of annoying to listen to and it
might even hurt your feelings that's the
downside so on one hand the downside is
tyranny on the other side on the other
hand the downside is hurt feelings what
which which one which which is the
better course of action it seems obvious
to me all right uh I guess I got to be
careful now
doing this show if ridicule is against
the law I might be I gotta be honest I'm
probably in a lot of trouble let's go to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com this is from
Trevor says your tweets about pit bulls
are what I expect from leftist should we
ban guns to your arguments against pit
bulls are the exact arguments leftist
use you need to get off this crusade
because you're embarrassing yourself pit
bulls don't kill people bad owners do in
all caps raise your pit bull right and
it's not a problem hi Trevor yes Trevor
references a back and forth on social
media between me and a bunch of pit bull
owners who are famously a pretty
irrational Bunch no offense it's just
that when it comes to social media mobs
I found that Beyonce fans are the most
irrational and then a close second would
be pit bull owners it kind of goes like
that and I'm probably Star Wars fans or
right after that's sort of the the
unholy trinity of irrational Twitter
mobs I don't remember what started this
particular round of argument on the
subject I think it was yeah it was it
was okay it was I saw a tweet that
someone posted and pit bull owners are
always doing this it's the dumbest
argument where they go oh yeah pit bulls
are real aggressive huh well well look
at this dangerous beast and then they
it's a picture of their pit bull you
know acutely snuggling on a on a on a
furry carpet next to a fireplace as if
that somehow proves that pit bulls are
safe as if as if a picture of a pit bull
not killing people proves that pit bulls
don't kill people as if the cuteness of
an animal somehow correlates with its
relative safety
now if that's true then grizzly bears I
guess are the safest animals in the
world
oh you think grizzly bears will eat your
face well look at this picture of a
grizzly bear not eating anyone's face
checkmates just really dumb here's the
statistical reality and you can go ahead
and you could google this in fact check
me don't take my word for it by far by
far the most lethal breed of dog in the
country is the pit bull they kill more
people than any other breed of dog it's
not close they win that horrible
competition by a landslide and that's
not even counting all the people who are
mold by pit balls pit bulls and and
don't die there's information on the
website dog bite law calm you can go
check it out it has a report showing
that in many parts of the country pit
bulls
not only lead in mauling deaths but they
also lead in dog bite incidents at all
period so they bite the most people and
they're the most likely to kill you when
they do bite you and this says nothing
of all the other dogs that are attacked
by pit bulls which is far more common
even than that let me read a quick email
from someone else who who sent me on
this subject someone who worked at an
animal shelter this is from Erin this is
what she had to say she said I'm a
registered veterinary technician from
California I worked at a municipal
animal shelter where we were where we
received the bike dogs to either keep
until their rabies hold was up or to
euthanize if the owners wanted a rabies
hold is the period of time a dog is kept
under observation to ensure the dog
doesn't have any rabies symptoms if no
rabies vaccine is on file bite dogs in
quotes come in many breeds and sizes but
the worst always the very worst bites
were bully breeds it was absolutely
terrifying the damage those dogs can and
will do I used to advocate for them and
I was staunchly against breeding
specific against breed specific
legislation but after seeing the damage
they do I wish they would breed them all
out multiple times a week we received
reports of these four-legged terrorists
ripping apart other animals and
generally once a week there was a tragic
human incident there's no reason for
this there are dozens of other breeds
out there
why are people so weird about bully
breeds and that's the thing about pit
bulls it's not just that they're
naturally aggressive though they are
it's that they're built biologically to
inflict maximum damage okay that that's
this is this is also why it's dumb to
own many other kinds of animals you see
people who have pythons as pets
now pythons can be temperamental but
that's not even the main point the point
is because they're snakes but the point
is that they are built to be killing
machines that's the problem and you hear
these tragic cases of a pet Python
killing a child or whatever it doesn't
happen that all that often but it does
happen and since it's an animal it's a
this is an animal we're talking about
right so you can never really know how
they're gonna react or what's going on
inside their head you can't reason with
them and you can't really ever trust
them completely because you don't know
what no nobody really understands animal
psychology nobody really understands
human psychology all the way forget
about animal psychology so when you you
have a pit please have a pit bull will
never do that my pit bulls are sweetie
you don't know what the hell your pit
bull is thinking you have no idea you
have no clue yes you could have general
sort of confidence that your particular
dog is safe but you can't know for sure
about any dog and you might say well
then what do you say we should you
should we should just get rid of all
dogs no I'm saying that because you can
never be sure with an animal because an
animal is an animal that's why it's
probably best not to bring animals into
your home that could kill somebody if
they wanted to there's just no good
reason to do that okay so it's what will
do this exercise again on the one hand
we have all the stats proving beyond any
doubt that pit bulls are the most
dangerous breed of dog we have all the
news stories of of pit bulls mauling
children to death we have all the other
dogs that have been mauled and killed by
pit bulls
and that's why you shouldn't own them as
far as why you should on the other hand
I mean what what to outweigh all of that
statistical information what can you
possibly present what's the argument for
owning them I'm not talking about an
argument that attempts to rationalize or
get around or evade the points that I
just made what is a positive affirmative
argument for why it is good to own them
because they're cute because you like
them it's just it's not a it's there's
no good reason for it
now as Trevor as for your arguments such
as they are you say the argument against
pit bulls is like making an argument
against gun rights this is enormous ly
stupid but I hear it from pit bull
people all the time it is such a bad
argument first of all guns are inanimate
objects they don't they don't have minds
of their own
they're not gonna hop over your fence
and go and shoot your neighbor's kid on
their own that's not gonna happen
dogs are not inanimate objects they are
animals with minds minds that we don't
fully understand so this analogy just
doesn't work the fact that dogs are not
inanimate objects and are animals that
cannot always be 100% controlled is the
point so to bring up some inanimate
object that has to be directly operated
by another person completely misses the
point second you don't have a
constitutional right to own whatever
animal you want so that's another reason
why that analogy doesn't work if you if
there was such a constitutional right
then you'd be able to own bears and
tigers and chimps and any law against
that would be unconstitutional which
obviously would be crazy so you say pit
bulls don't kill people bad owners do
now that's wrong pit bulls definitely do
kill people they do that's just a fact
now there might be pit bull owners who
also kill people but that's a separate
subject the fact is pit bulls kill you
pit bulls are living creatures they
aren't robots they aren't remote control
toys pit bulls kill people on their own
yes
they do to the bad owner thing okay you
hear this too this is the other this is
the other common rationalization Oh pit
bulls it's all about the owner sure I
agree that a pit bull with a bad owner
is going to probably be more dangerous
than a pit bull with a good owner but
how do you ensure that the owners are
good what does it mean to be a good
owner and how do you ensure that are we
doing are we doing yearly checkups to
make sure that the owner is still doing
everything he's supposed to do how could
you possibly know there might be some
basic red flags you can look for like
has this person been convicted of
dogfighting before okay well then yeah
sure that's probably not someone that
should get a pit bull but other than
that if it's just a normal-looking
person coming in to adopt a pit bull how
are you supposed to know if they're good
or not
and besides isn't it really foolish and
reckless and insane to bring an animal
into your home who might rip you apart
limb from limb if you are not fully
attentive to it all the time and a
perfect owner in every way people tell
me you just got to get pit bulls a lot
of attention okay but if you don't give
them attention then what they'll kill
something yeah I agree
yes if you have one give it attention do
all that stuff but the the problem is
that the the downside to not being a
great owner is immense and it's not fair
to put your community in that position
where we have to pay the price if you
fail as an owner now if somebody owns a
poodle and they're not a great poodle
owner then what does the community have
to deal with they have to deal with that
yapping dog which is pretty annoying and
worst case the dog bites somebody and it
hurts and there's a little bit of a mark
and you know and and and that's it
that's the worst case with a poodle if
you were to compare all of the people
all of the humans in history who have
been killed by poodles I doubt it would
even add up to how many people that the
pit bulls kill in one in one year so
that's the issue other kinds of dogs if
you have a owner who isn't great
that's not good but the price the
community will have to pay is relatively
negligible the problem though with a
pitbull is the price the community has
to pay if you're not raising the dog
right is potentially fatal and so maybe
it's best just to not bring those
animals into a community you know just
choose from any of the other dog breeds
you don't need that one
okay this is from Kyle says dear Matt I
wanted to get your opinion on a recent
experience I had the gas station I've
honestly never run into this but my wife
said it happens to her regularly and I
wanted to get your thoughts I was at a
gas station with my family and every
pump was occupied I chose one where I
thought the car ahead of me was about to
leave but the occupant started walking
in the direction of the convenience
store he looked at my car sitting in a
position where my intention to put gas
in my car could not be misunderstood and
I firmly believe he started walking
slower in shock and desperation I looked
at the next pump where the man was
carefully washing every single glass
surface on the outside of his car with
the squeegee and he wasn't
simultaneously pumping gas I could not
believe the level of rudeness these two
people exhibited I have less issue with
either of these activities if the gas
station is empty or even if you're
trying to kill two birds with one stone
while pumping gas at the same time but
doing it while you're watching people
wait for a pump is outrageous would this
crime be worthy of the death penalty
when you are supreme dictator yes Kyle
to go first of all I'm sorry you had to
go through that and so you have my
condolences to go to the convenience
store after you've already pumped the
gas when all the pumps are full rather
than just drive to the actual parking
spots because every every gas station
with a convenience store attached also
has its own parking spaces that are not
next to pumps that you could just drive
over - but - but because you don't feel
like doing that leaving your car in the
spot while it's busy is beyond the
bounds of human decency I completely
agree with you Kyle sociopathic does
not even begin to describe it honestly
there is no excuse it should go without
saying if it's a busy gas station you
pump your gas and you get the hell out
you know you don't start you don't pass
go collect 200 you don't do any of that
pump your gas get out
you don't squeegee you don't go to the
convenience store you don't start
clearing out all the old Pepsi bottles
and coffee cups from the floor of your
passenger side you know you don't do any
of that you don't sit there and text on
your phone pump and go I agree with you
Kyle this should be understood common
practice but you know we there are
people who are barbarians in this
society Kyle as for penalties under my
regime if you go into the store and you
leave that your car there when you come
out to your car it will be doused it
will be doused in gasoline and it will
be on fire and then you will be expected
to pay for the additional gasoline that
had to be used in order to torch your
car and then you know what's coming next
you are going to be thrown into the fire
now you might argue that this will only
slow the process down more now that
we've had to you know do a an execution
via fire in the middle of the gas
station you might also argue that it
could be potentially dangerous that we
have this huge fire right next to a
bunch of gas pumps but listen these are
sacrifices that I would be willing to
make to see that justice is done and I
want you to know that you have my solemn
promise that I will go to any lengths as
long as I am NOT personally
inconvenience but to see that justice is
done vote for me and we will leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thank you for listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright V Lee Weyer 2019 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over at the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]